très ému au milieu de la journée
déjeuner réunissait quelques 200
personnes autour du chef de l'état
personnalités françaises et étrangères
du monde politique scientifiques ou
culturelles des proches des amis un
repas sans protocole placée sous le
signe de l'amitié
après quoi le programme officiel
reprenait avec la visite à l'hôtel de
ville de paris
c'est une foule enthousiaste qui attend
françois mitterrand et son épouse à la
mairie de paris vers 17h20 où ils sont
accueillis par jacques chirac
c'est la troisième fois de la journée
que le maire de paris va serrer la main
du nouveau chef d'état
il entre dans le salon des tapisseries
françois mitterrand salue quelques uns
des invités de jacques chirac
voici son épouse et bernadette chirac
le président de la république signe
alors le livre d'or de la ville de paris
puis le parchemin attestant sa visite à
l'hôtel de ville
et jacques chirac lui remet la médaille
d'or de la capitale
salué au passage par la garde
républicaine les deux hommes gagnent par
l'escalier d'honneur le grand salon de
l'hôtel de ville
ils vont prendre successivement la
parole en présence de pierre me vois
jacques chaban delmas et les invités
au seuil d'un nouveau septennat qui
affirme la volonté du changement
il me paraît particulièrement nécessaire
de rappeler que rien de grand ni le
solide ni de durable ne peut être
accomplie sans référence à la continuité
profonde de notre histoire telle que
paris en porte témoignage
vous l'avez dit monsieur le maire il y a
beaucoup à faire mais rien ne se fera
sans la fraternité et rien son injustice
en cet instant où il est possible
d'abandonner ne serait-ce qu'un moment
l'âpreté des compétitions politiques qui
mieux que le président de la république
mesure l'effort à accomplir
qui mieux que lui peut exprimer la
profonde volonté d'union de notre peuple
françois mitterrand et jacques chirac
gagne ensuite salon cheney où ils vont
s'entretenir pendant plusieurs minutes
au milieu d'un cercle restreint de
personnalités
cet entretien a marqué la fin de cette
cérémonie qui rituellement veut que le
président de la république réserve sa
première visite officielle à la mairie
de paris
françois mitterrand quitte l'hôtel de
ville et remonte alors le boulevard
saint michel en voiture sous les vivats
de la foule
il tourne rue soufflot et décent
c'est à pied et avec le peuple de paris
qu'il va gravir cette rue qui le conduit
au panthéon
c'est le premier bien de foule du
président de la république c'est aussi
la rupture avec les cérémonies
officielles de la journée l' orchestre
de paris placée sous la direction de
daniel barenboïm accompagne le président
regardez
m
où
françois mitterrand se dégage de la
foule de rose à la main
il pénètre seul à l'intérieur du
panthéon
orchestre de paris joue maintenant
l'hymne à la joie
le président de la république va se
recueillir devant le tombeau de jean
jaurès et du résistant jean moulin
ban
comme vous avez pu le constater sur les
images que vous avez vu il ya un instant
nombreux étaient les personnalités
étrangères du monde politique ou du
monde des arts venu féliciter le nouveau
président à ses amis se sont retrouvés
aux différentes manifestations notamment
au déjeuner dans la cour de lui